his career best eight tackles last week
completion and a stunts
right there the quick hit and tackled
defensive coordinator Ola Adams told us
this week this game is all about the
first quarter I've told the players
we've got to hold up they did not hold
up on that first play now here's Jared
Hayek catches thrown down Joey Porter Jr
Juan brisker the safeties
both of them are in the game right now
as Daniel Smith will throw it to his
tight end Todd Summers
has to check it down to Carr who's in
trouble and tackled to the line of
scrimmage nice play by Joey Porter they
can get right back in the game here
five-man Rush panics keeps backing up
lost one up and it is picked off if he's
in bounds Joey Porter has it and it is
Penn State ball and his band fry Fogle
didn't get it yeah it was almost like he
was caught between trying to throw this
away throwing out of bounds or let his
guy make a catch but because he couldn't
step into the throw because of the
pressure of lucata the ball just hung it
hung up in the air for an eternity and
Porter came underneath it to make the
interception and he was inbounds have
possession third down and one
and he'll hand it off on the end around
Sheffield lost it because Penn State
have it
yes they do Joey Porter watch what I'm
about to talk about you've got this both
tight ends they were back off the line
of scrimmage Gus did you see that yes
and so when you bring the Jet Sweep
across that motion he's further back in
the backfield then you want him if
you're the the center is going to be
under Center and try to turn around and
handsome that's why he was trying to
reach and I don't think Sheffield ever
really got that ball cleanly I think a
lot of it had to do with the formation
those tight ends were lined up as kind
of winged back so they could try to get
around the edge we got all out
man-to-man get the ball out
flip it out to Washington looking for a
block at the five and he's down inside
the two he's able to create a little
space second and six this time near side
dropped at the line of scrimmage but
again and there's a whiff on the outside
so quarterback run has been their only
ground attack they'll try to set up a
little Crosser here and fighting for
yardage the old quarterback Donovan
McCully but he's at least a couple of
yards